Hello.
How's it going?
It's Friday.
And we're all here together.
I promise this hours,
I'm going to call it a power hour.
It'll be a little less than an hour.
Cause I know you're on your lunch break and you guys are like in the middle of
the workday.
But I am here to Jesuit and really inspire you because I've been on my own
personal journey,
which turned into a book called the Self Love Experiment.
So as we get started,
I want to ask you a question and just think about this for a moment and I will
ask you to share with the person next to you.
So you know that's kind of fun,
right?
Get Cozy.
Think about someone who really inspires you.
It could be a mentor or a boss,
a teacher,
a best friend.
Maybe it's someone you don't know,
a public figure and author.
Just kidding.
Most of you probably don't at me.
So,
but no,
think about someone who inspires you and what are the qualities of an empowered
person?
Okay.
So just take a quick moment workshop with each other
so you can say who it is and what,
why they inspire you.
Okay,
so we'll come back to the group.
Does anyone want to share just all I,
all I want to hear is just maybe qualities of the inspiring person.
Just shout them out.
Self-Empowered just qualities of that empire in,
in Po empowered person.
Determined,
empowering other people.
Yes.
Confidence.
Passionate.
Yes.
These are great words.
Anyone else?
Qualities of the empowered person.
Happy,
driven.
All of these honest,
these are amazing.
So these qualities are also qualities of self love.
These qualities are also qualities of an empowered person.
Someone who is standing in their truth.
And today I'm going to help you.
Yes,
I'll be talking about my experiment in my experience in writing my book.
But I'm here to help you stand in your truth.
Because my ultimate goal is that when people ask that question,
you say,
I empower me.
I'm empowered and inspired by me because I've worked really hard to get to where
I am in my life and I'm super excited where I'm going to go.
So that's where we're going today.
And so when you first hear the word self love,
what are some of the things you guys think of?
We're here today at a lunch break to talk about self love.
Anybody kind of think,
maybe it's selfish,
you don't have to raise your hand,
but I hear that a lot.
Narcissistic,
little bit selfish a little bit.
Uh,
right.
I used to think that.
I used to think that for many,
many years.
In fact,
it was at war with myself for almost three decades.
I hated myself.
I hated my body.
I blamed my body for everything I didn't make the dance team in high school was
my body's fault.
I Amanda and call me back whenever,
didn't call me back.
It was always me,
my body to blame.
And it didn't matter what size my body was because I used to be a triathlete.
I would run half marathons every other weekend.
I would participate in half iron man triathlons.
So I looked really healthy on the outside.
I looked really fit,
looked like I had it together.
I haven't always been an author.
I haven't always been talking to people and writing books.
In fact,
several years ago,
all through my twenties I was in corporate,
I was in advertising.
Anybody have friends in advertising,
especially here.
Right?
And I was climbing the corporate ladder,
living in Chicago,
and it looks like I had it all together.
I was dating a man who wanted to marry me and I was making a lot of money,
so much money.
I didn't even know what to do with it yet.
I was in a lot of debt,
so much debt,
wipe my sweat here.
And I got to a point where I said something's got to give.
Because on the outside it looked like I had everything.
But on the inside of his crying myself to sleep every single night I was
suffering from eating disorders.
And my doctor diagnosed me with clinical depression.
So it was actually a point in my life where we can't look and judge people and
say buy on the outside how they look,
because everyone's having their own internal experience.
And so I got to a place where I said,
you know what?
Something has to change.
And my inner voice.
I said,
depression,
why are you here?
What could you possibly teach me?
And my depression said,
follow your heart.
You're sad because you're not being true to yourself.
So I got up the courage to follow my heart,
which meant leaving advertising,
leaving Chicago and moving back to Portland,
Oregon,
where I grew up and finding my passion for writing and speaking and leading
retreats.
And through this process I started to write books and I found the most joyous
activity in the world.
They found my life passion through writing and when I was promoting my first
book called find your happy,
which talks about how to be happy.
I was going on tour and I was getting ready to go on the morning television show
in Seattle.
And the night before I was in the hotel room and I was looking in the mirror and
I was crying because here I was going to go on TV and I was going to talk to
people about how to be happy because I had been much happier than I was.
I had worked through the addictions.
I had overcome the depression.
Here I was living my dream job,
but I couldn't say one good thing about myself.
I hated myself.
I said,
how happy can you be if you don't love yourself?
And that's where the self love experiment was born.
So this was several years ago.
But through the process I started to do research and excuse me,
what I discovered is that 90 of women hate their bodies,
ladies,
90% of us.
And I discovered that 95% of people absolutely want to change something about
themselves.
So just take a look at the room.
Almost all of us,
we have something we dislike and it gets worse.
Six out of 10 people actually opt out of important activities because of a flaw
or insecurity.
So this is actually controlling our life.
Okay?
So an insecurity blocks us from showing up.
And that's when I realized the self love experiment has to happen to save my
life because I was not living my life.
I was letting my insecurities hold me back and I was preventing myself from
living my potential.
And that's what I offer to you today to think about what is that problem,
the flaw,
the insecurity that you feel has been stopping you from moving forward.
Just take a moment.
I call it the almost paradise syndrome.
It's the,
when I lose the weight,
I'll be happier when I get the promotion,
when I moved to the city I really want to be in.
When I get that x,
Y,
Z,
then maybe my life can start.
But guess what?
Most of the time when we get that we realize we're still not happy.
I lost all the weight.
I still wasn't happy.
I got that dream job.
Something was missing.
And so at the core of every single thing we want in our life is empowerment,
self love.
So we chase it and we look for it outside of ourselves,
but really it's inside inside of ourselves.
So today I have a process I'm going to take you through,
but I first want to talk a little bit about what the self love experiment
actually is and how I got to learning how to love myself fully.
Because truly I stand her up here in front of you,
loving myself,
every fiber of my body.
Even though I sweat in front of people all the time,
it doesn't matter.
I'm sitting on the couch and I sweat.
And so it really becomes about showing up as you are,
no matter where you are and letting yourself be seen.
Let yourself be who you are.
So what is the self love experiment?
It had three goals.
Number one,
I wanted to lighten up.
How many of us want to lighten up right spiritually,
emotionally,
physically,
mentally.
I was taking life so serious.
I would go out to dinner or lunch with friends and I couldn't be present because
I was so focused on how the next bite I took would put me over my calorie limit.
My best friend called me and said,
I'm getting married.
I want you to be in the wedding.
And my first thought,
this is before the self love experiment was not,
I'm so excited for you.
Yes,
I can't wait to be in the wedding.
It was holy crap.
Do I have enough time to lose the weight?
And I wasn't overweight at all.
Then.
So we have these things about ourselves and really the war that's happening is
inside our head.
The inner critic is driving us and that's why this book is out.
And that's why I did the self love experiment.
So just as I take you through the process,
think about where your insecurities have been blocking you.
What flaw do you wake up in the morning and focus on because this process,
we'll reverse it.
This process we'll let you be who you are in a world that tries to tell you to
change because the world is going to keep saying be smarter,
richer,
prettier,
thinner,
go chase,
whatever.
But the real magic of the self love experiment and also being alive is to say,
guess what?
I'm not going to subscribe to that anymore because that's where our anxiety
comes from.
It's where the depression and the addictions come from.
I was able to heal my depression and my eating disorders and find my life
purpose and passion by discovering self love.
So the second part and the second goal of myself I've experiment was to say only
nice things about myself.
Can I look in the mirror and say kind things?
Yes,
it's possible.
What do you say to yourself when you look in the mirror?
Let's turn it into a kind conversation.
And then the third,
the third goal was to see myself the way my dog does.
Any dog lovers,
animal lovers,
cats.
Do you ever notice how they see you and you're the most amazing thing in the
world?
I want it to be the coolest,
most beautiful,
awesome person in the world because they don't judge you,
they love you no matter what.
That's really the ultimate expression of the self love experiment.
And those goals are realized through the process.
So you have to,
and I had to realize that I have to treat it like an experiment.
So like a scientist,
right?
You go into it,
you have some type of goal.
But really it's the process.
Each experiment that you do,
each thing you try is going to move you one step closer to possibly what it is
you want.
So instead of putting the expectation on each thing you do,
you say,
guess what?
I learned from this.
Now I'm going to try something else.
So the experiment is actually what I think we should try to do for our life.
What if we looked at our life as an experiment and we took off the expectations
and we stopped saying,
I have to do this to get here.
I should do this.
So much pressure we put on ourselves.
So the experiment is super important and I encourage you guys to look at how you
can take,
take your weekend going into the weekend and say,
I'm going to make this an experiment.
What am I going to do that's going to be more fun,
more playful,
and I'll be in the process.
So about three months into my self love experiment,
I started to say,
okay,
this is working.
I'm feeling good about myself.
But not all the time.
It was kind of fleeting,
right?
So I was at my mom's house and you guys know the coloring books where you can
color,
they were really popular a few years ago.
They might still be popular.
And mine had a mantra on it that said everything happens for a reason and had
butterflies and flowers and I didn't know that that was a universal sign right
there.
But I was coloring and I was talking in my mom and I,
one of my best friends talking about our dreams and goals.
About three months into myself,
love experiment I,
and she started to bring up conversation about some friends of ours that were
getting married and it triggered something in me.
It didn't even matter who they were.
I started to cry a woman in her mid thirties very successful in her career.
It looks again like she has happiness,
which I was happy to talk about that in a second,
how to not chase the happiness and I was crying and she said,
why are you crying?
What's the matter?
She put her pencil down and I said,
mom,
do you think anyone can love me the way that I am?
And that was right there.
The core of my biggest limiting belief,
I felt unlovable.
What I was really asking and I didn't know at the time was,
do you think I can love myself the way that I am?
And of course she put her pencil down right away and she said,
she it don't ever say that about yourself.
Of course the mother would never want to hear that
in the next thing she said is was the most important thing that really kicked in
the self love experiment and change my life forever.
She said,
Shannon,
the most important thing is that you're happy and if you're not happy at this
body size,
then maybe this isn't the size for you.
Now,
she meant this with so much love and compassion and this is what we hear a lot.
I grew up with this,
but in that moment I rejected that because I said,
no,
that's not the answer because for my whole life I've tried to change myself to
be happy.
Whether it was 40 pounds underweight or 60 70 pounds overweight,
the problem is not outside of me.
So in her saying that I decided I'm going to stop asking everyone else and I'm
going to go inward and start to trust myself.
And that was the most revolutionary thing that I could do.
Because I was also saying,
guess what society that says I should be smaller or I can't be happy until I
have this amount of money in the bank.
Or I'm with my soul mate,
a woman who was single in her mid thirties what's wrong with her?
All these things we say to ourselves.
But in that moment I said,
nope.
The goal is for me to learn how to love myself as I am.
And that is what the self love experiment is.
Because we all have things we want to change about ourselves.
But learning how to love yourself does not have to mean you have to change
yourself from a place of self hate.
It means you can take pro,
take steps to move forward and be more kind and compassionate with yourself from
a loving place.
So that was really the key.
And so it is not outside of ourselves.
The answer is really on the inside.
And so how did I get to hear today from crying on my mom's living room and
crying in the bathroom,
I did a self love experiment and it was the most glorious thing I've ever done
as a writer.
It turned into a book.
I didn't know it was going to be a book when I started at,
but this book healed me because I found self love.
I stand up here loving every single fiber of my body and showing up as I am.
And that is the key for all of you to show up through your insecurities,
to show up through the things you think you need to change because you are
enough as you are.
So I have a process,
three things that I'm going to share with you and then we'll kind of do a Q and
a and a that's,
that's how we'll go.
So there's actually,
the book is actually divided in different layers because there's layers to self
love.
So I take people through a process.
The first layer is self care.
Okay?
When you guys hear self care,
a lot of times in the wellness industry especially we hear drink your green
juice,
doing your yoga,
go to soul cycle,
which is really fun by the way.
I just did it.
So we get so wrapped up in having to be,
and do we stay in this box,
right?
The wellness community and just being taking care of yourself.
I got to a point where I realized I am sick of Yoga.
I don't want any more 30 day hot challenge yoga challenges.
I'm done with it.
I don't want any more Kale Salad.
And I said,
what does self care really mean?
And I discovered it's about joy.
What brings you joy?
And that is why also when I said a lot of us are chasing happiness,
we never really get there because happiness isn't is a feeling.
It's something that we'll elude us.
Whereas joy is an experience.
It's a PR,
it's a process,
but it's a way of living.
So I truly believe that joy is the best barometer for success in any layer,
in any level of your life.
Whether it's a relationship,
whether it's a career,
whether it's trying to reach your goal of losing weight or going on your dream
vacation,
joy.
So how can you put more joy into your life right now?
So I started to do that and I realized I wanted more nature walks with my dog.
I wanted to join a spinning studio instead of to do in the yoga.
And so I started to fill myself up.
I started to cook more,
I started to do things that felt good and made me feel alive.
So ask yourself,
what makes you feel alive?
That's the most caring thing you can do for yourself.
If you love camping,
get out and go camping.
If you love animals,
go adopt a pet.
You know there's things we can do to bring more joy into our life right now.
So that's one part of the process.
But I'm going to share three of the principals that really stand out that I
think can help you guys in your own life as well.
And at the back of the book there's 15 principals.
So I'm pulling out the highlighted ones.
So I think we have to first ask ourselves,
how do you know when you're lacking self love?
Because I didn't know that I didn't love myself.
I just knew that my experience of life was difficult.
A lot of times we don't walk around saying I don't love myself.
It's in our actions.
It's in our behavior.
It's in the way.
We're always trying for something more than what is.
And so anybody wonder like throw out.
Why do you think,
what would be an example of when we don't love ourselves?
Rejection.
Yeah.
When we feel rejection.
So good.
One of the main ones is when we compare ourselves to other people
and I get,
I bet if we get really honest with ourselves,
we've probably compared ourselves to someone else within the past three or four
days.
Right?
Especially at work.
And then also when we compare ourselves to our self.
You may have had a different version of you five years ago,
a skinny are you one who was in a different job or when,
who was in a different relationship.
And like,
man,
if only I could go back or maybe not go back,
but what happened?
Or we look to the future part of us and we're like,
gosh,
that person out there,
I'm not there yet.
And not in the body I want or the career,
whatever it may be.
So we compare ourselves to other people,
but we also compare ourselves to ourselves.
And this is detrimental,
but it's part of being human.
You cannot get out of it.
And so I'm going to share a process with you to help you if you fall into
comparison because judgment and comparison keeps us from love.
Judging is a form of fear.
It's a form of lack that I'm not enough and what that person has is better and
they're deserving and I'm not.
And we go into this cycle where we spin out of control.
Now the trick and the goal with the self love experiment is to give you guys
tools,
lots of tools to help you feel empowered in your life.
And one of the tools is to work through judgements.
And I actually have a three part process that I'll share with you right now.
Number one is to recognize when you're comparing yourself to other people,
they are just showing you what is possible.
So for example,
I'm a book author,
I have a book,
obviously that just came out,
but in September there's amazing books coming out too from some of my favorite
authors who have been writing for much longer,
meet amazing people and their books are already like number one and then they
haven't even come out.
So my mind is like,
oh my gosh,
I just read this book and these people have a book coming out in a month.
What's happening?
They're doing better.
And I fall into,
oh no,
before my self love experiment,
I would have carried that energy all through my tour.
I would have,
you know,
showed up and been like gone to bed each night feeling not enough.
Right.
But the self love experiment gave me the process of saying,
Oh yes,
they're showing me what's possible.
Thank you.
I can have that because if we didn't compare ourselves,
there's so many things going on in the world.
We don't compare ourselves to everyone.
The ones we compare ourselves to are usually the ones that show us something
within us that we want,
which means it's already within us to have.
It's just about becoming who you need to be to get to where you to to receive
that and so to recognize,
thank you.
You're showing me what's possible.
I see this can be an option for my life if I want it.
And then number two is to immediately go into appreciation,
appreciation for your own life.
So I turned my attention right away too.
Oh my gosh.
I just,
I wrote a book and I get to go travel all over the country and I get to just
celebrate self love.
How awesome.
Also celebrate the people who are showing up for you.
Appreciate the things that are going well in your life because if we keep
focusing on what's not going well,
we stay stuck.
We stay in lack.
So I want you to take a moment right now to just think about what you are
appreciative of and give thanks just for a moment.
I won't ask you to share this time.
Okay.
So this practice of appreciation is one of the best and fastest ways to move
forward.
I helped heal my depression when I was in corporate hating my job,
hating my life by first very first step,
turning to appreciation.
So if we ever felt trapped by life,
circumstances and victimized by the world,
then we can go to what can I be appreciative?
I have?
What can I be thankful for right now?
And then from that place you can step forward.
It's a much more loving energy.
So I did the same thing with the things I hated about myself.
How can I appreciate my overweight belly or my chin or with all of the things
that we say we don't like about ourselves?
And if you can't get there,
then focus on the things you do appreciate about yourself.
You might love your nose or your hair or the way your positive and happy or the
way you're trying to be positive and show up for yourself one step at a time.
So it's about one step at a time,
which is the process and they experiment.
And then the third,
if you're in comparison,
is to stand by you.
And what I mean by this is to give yourself what it is you really need and want.
So in this experience of comparing myself to other authors,
I recognized what I really wanted,
which was appreciation.
I had a book come out,
I wanted recognition,
I wanted love.
So the magic is to give that to yourself.
Here I was right before I started my book tour,
seeing all these other authors trending all over on the New York Times list,
all this stuff.
And I said,
wow,
I haven't even given myself appreciation.
I haven't even shown myself love because I've been so busy the past couple of
weeks.
So give yourself what it is you need.
And all of a sudden you will feel more empowered.
What I needed was recognition.
So I said,
Shannon,
you wrote a book.
I hadn't told myself that at all.
So what can you recognize yourself for?
What can you celebrate yourself for?
What can you lift yourself up for?
One step at a time?
Starts up here and then the very next day my agent talked to me and I looked at
the numbers and I saw that my book,
the self over experiment was trending on Amazon.
Number one in self esteem.
And I say this only because I believe this process works.
When you show up for yourself and get out of what's going on out there and
returned to inside your an empowered person moving forward,
you have the power to control the outcome by being in the space of love and
compassion for yourself.
And so the second one,
actually there's a principal I'll share with you for this,
the it's number one,
the principle number one is to accept where you are.
It's just a point in your journey and everything about the,
everything about it offers possibility for growth and expansion.
So when it looks like comparing yourself to others,
recognize where you are accepted and then from that place you can move forward
in that place,
you'll feel more charged up.
So what can you accept in your life right now?
There's that famous Chinese proverb except what you can't change.
Change what you can accept.
It really does start with acceptance.
Okay,
so the second one I'll share with you today.
This is the barrier that blocks us.
And when we know we're out of self love,
it's when we feel hopeless or we feel like self love is selfish or we feel like,
how dare I care about myself?
So here's the thing,
there's so much going on in the world right now.
Disasters,
political uproar,
there's a lot of fear.
Terrorists like it's crazy out there.
And we can easily fall into feeling depressed and feeling hopeless.
And I did this about two months before my book was coming out.
There was so much,
I was watching the news every day,
which I suggest you don't do.
It was crazy.
I know we're in New York,
but like,
ah,
it was crazy.
And I said,
how?
Who am I to go talk about self love.
I have a book about loving yourself,
how,
how dare anyone focus on them when there's the world that needs saving.
And I caught myself right away because I said something that actually helped me
in my own self love experiment is that suddenly it made sense to stop hating
myself is to raise the vibration on the planet,
to stop being negative to myself is to actually do my part,
to uplift the entire world.
Because that's one less person hurting.
That's one less person in pain and that's one less person stuck in negativity.
So we owe it to ourselves to show up for ourselves because from that place we
can do so much more good.
We can give more time,
more energy,
more love to those who need it.
And that was a revolutionary change for me.
And it turned into a principal in the self love experiment,
which is when you heal yourself,
you help to heal the world,
you can make the most profound difference in the world by focusing on yourself
first,
to forgive yourself,
to honor yourself and love yourself from that place.
You make really empowered choices.
Guess what?
Hurt people hurt people.
People who are in pain affect other people.
When I was depressed,
I wanted to help people.
I'm starting my life coaching practice and it's hard to show up fully when
you're stuck in your stuckness.
You just can't.
We do it because we have big hearts.
All of us in here have huge hearts.
You wouldn't be in a self love experiment lunch if you didn't have a big heart.
And so we show up and we say,
you know what?
I want to be even more empowered.
And we do that by first being kind and compassionate to ourselves.
So I want to invite you guys to ask yourself,
where have you been blowing yourself off?
Where have you been saying this?
This deserves more attention.
I'm not going to show up for me,
this is more important.
I will skip that thing.
That is really important to me.
My dreams don't matter.
I'll just wait.
Just ask yourself and maybe go into the weekend thinking about how can I show up
for myself more?
How can I be more present in my life and put more love into the equation right
now.
So I'm gonna move into the third reason.
A lot of us actually do not feel self love without even realizing it.
Anyone want to guess?
No guesses.
I'll just share self doubt and fear,
right?
When we're in self doubt and what this looks like is we believe our insecurities
are real.
We believe the problems about us are actually the problems.
So Tony Robbins,
you guys know Tony Robbins,
America's life coach,
huge motivational speaker.
That's what he calls himself.
He says,
problems need energy to grow.
If you do not give your problems energy,
then guess what?
They won't.
They won't manifest bigger and take up so much time and space in our life.
What problem are you focusing on?
Now?
There's a difference between a problem that you look for the solution,
right?
And your work,
especially with what you guys do here.
There's a part of showing up,
but going immediately to the solution is the key instead of festering in the
problem and letting it overcome you.
So the problems that we have in our life,
the insecurities we have,
the fears we have often look like self doubt.
I don't feel good enough.
I don't feel worthy enough for me.
I didn't feel lovable.
And so ask yourself,
what self doubt in your life is blocking you from moving forward?
So self doubt.
Here's the thing about it,
it shows up in every layer of our life.
So I am up here and I truly do love myself and I'm excited about the
possibilities.
But self doubt,
a couple of weeks ago before I left for my tour came roaring in a lot of what
was going on in the world,
right?
And I sat there for a moment,
I said,
what's going on?
This is like crippling self doubt.
And for a couple minutes I sat there before myself.
Love experiment.
I would have let it control my outcome.
I may have even been canceled some events I may have just like hindered in my
bed and cover it up or eaten lots ice cream.
Like all these things we do over work,
over spend,
overeat over,
exercise we over the situation.
I invite you guys to feel what comes up.
So I sat there with my self doubt and I'm gonna invite you guys to do this,
to put your hand on your heart.
If you want the right hand,
anytime you feel self doubt,
just return to yourself in the moment.
Put your hand here and you say hello.
Hello you right.
And you can say,
what do you here to show me the same.
The same way that I asked my depression,
what are you here to show me?
And myself doubt came through and it said,
are you sure?
Are you sure you don't want to stay small?
Because self doubt wants us to stay small fear and our negative voice wants us
to retreat back to what is comfortable and what we know.
It's predictable,
it's manageable,
it's something we know.
Whereas anytime you're growing,
anytime you're dreaming and anytime you're stepping into the next level of your
life,
your self doubt,
we'll get louder.
And I said in that moment with my hand on my heart quickly and it said,
are you sure you want to stay small?
And my heart roared through and said,
are you kidding?
You were born for this.
Every single one of you was born for this,
to work through that self doubt,
to step forward and be empowered and choose you.
Your life is your masterpiece.
We've hear this,
right?
We hear this,
but I want you to really feel this.
Anytime you fall into fear,
insecurity,
self,
lack of self worth,
or I'm not good enough,
or gosh,
that person has what I want returned to right here.
Put your hand on your heart.
Say I love me,
or I'm doing the best I can each day and that is enough.
One step at a time we can get there.
And so what I offered to you guys with this principle,
the self love experiment,
principle number three is we get what we focus on.
So are you focusing on how it's not going to work?
How everything you've tried before is not moving forward?
Then that's going to keep creating what we want.
Are you focusing on the problem it's growing?
Take your attention off of it and focus on what you truly want.
Love,
empowerment,
acceptance.
And you'll start to see the results in your life much more clear.
So I'm going to offer to you guys as we close out the little speech here,
my wish for you is that next time someone asks you,
who empowers you,
you immediately say,
you know what?
I'm empowered by me and I'm,
I'm not shy from that and I'm not unapologetic because you guys are amazing.
You work really hard and you show up every day and you're doing the best you
can.
So start telling yourself that.
Start to really feel that because that's how we can move and help and change the
world.
I believe that.
So I welcome you and invite you to dive into the self love experiment.
That's it.
I like it.
She's like,
ah,
that was fantastic.
Shannon,
thank you so much for being here.
Like what a great speech.
What a great book by the way,
if you guys haven't read it to yourself a favor.
Um,
we talked a lot about the inner critic.
I think that we can all relay,
especially being here.
Um,
we're very much sometimes under a lot of pressure and there's a lot of,
um,
a lot of production I think that needs to happen.
Um,
and you also talk a little bit about how in her,
in her credit,
especially for you led to a lot of self sabotage and,
and,
and so on and sober.
How,
how do you think that we just in general as a culture or even yourself lead or
just sort of,
uh,
experienced self sabotage and how does that coming through in our lives?
I think,
yeah.
So self sabotage happens in so many ways,
right?
It happens by us shying away from what we really want.
Right?
Like,
like I've mentioned a couple of times,
I'm just a sweaty person.
Like I could not,
I could have chosen not to be a public speaker,
right?
But I'm so passionate about my message that I let that I,
it just,
it is what it is.
So you get to a point where you accept what is and when we shy away from what it
is we really want because of a part of us that we feel isn't good enough,
it's really us not honoring our living,
our potential.
And so it also looks like overspending,
like I said,
over eating over,
over anything.
Because a lot of times we're afraid to feel that what's really there.
So I would ask also sometimes when we wake up in the morning,
what do you say to yourself about yourself?
If you don't do as good in the meeting or if you don't,
you know,
you go home and you didn't get everything on your list on how are you talking to
yourself?
So I think it does come back to being a friend to yourself first and foremost,
and that's how we can stop
forward.
Excellent.
Yeah,
you stay,
and I'm going to read a quote from the book.
Learning how to love me has been the most difficult thing I've ever had to do.
A,
not because loving yourself as particular harbor because I had to unlearn all
the things I was conditioned to believe about self love.
I think it goes back to what you were saying earlier about narcissism or sort
that be able sometimes when you think that self love is sort of is a little self
righteous.
How are those green,
uh,
how those beliefs sort of ingrained,
and,
and how does that reflect on what self love or self,
what self care means for us?
Right.
Yeah.
And I think that's key.
Um,
it's like so many of us are kind of like chasing the,
let me see that this one,
right?
Yeah.
So in the we're,
we're this feeling,
right?
And that's really what I was talking about in the book.
Learning how to love myself was hard because if your parents didn't love
yourself,
they did the best they could.
Right.
If society and the media is always telling us to change ourselves,
everyone's just doing what they know how to do.
But I had to unlearn all of that from a very young age.
We're taught,
we have to look a certain way,
be a certain way,
talk a certain way,
right.
In our family or in society.
And so self love is often about being who you are as you are.
And that is the most self love is freedom.
Well we're chasing what we really want is freedom in that happiness,
in that paradise,
in that job,
in that more money,
in that soul mate relationship.
What we really want is to be seen for who we are.
So for me personally,
I was just so much of my life I was trying to be seen.
I was like looking,
I was like,
you know,
comparing myself,
see me,
but I wasn't seeing myself.
And so I think we have to really allow ourselves to be honest about who we are
and celebrate who we are.
Excellent.
Um,
do you regret your earlier life of a drug addiction or eating disorders or
depression?
That's a good question.
It's a heavy question,
but your question for work environment,
but you know,
uh,
I don't regret any phase of my life at all.
In fact,
I'm so thankful for it.
While I was in it,
it was very hard and very depressing and dark.
But I think we all have phases in our life that are hard,
depressing,
and dark.
And when we can be aware while we're in it say that this is part of maybe
something bigger is looking back,
I wouldn't be able to write a book about self love if I didn't hate myself.
I wouldn't be able to do what I love if I didn't experience those.
So I think it's really about allowing yourself to go through each phase of life.
Yeah.
Does anybody want to ask any questions from the audience Q and a time about
anything in the world?
Anything.
What are your plans for the weekend?
How are you doing?
Joy?
Yeah.
Oh Hi.
My name is Pankaj Makati.
Thank you so much for sharing your self love experience.
So the question is,
you said,
uh,
accept yourself as you are,
but uh,
to improve in anything you do or as a person,
you need to constantly analyze yourself or act your own critique.
Yes.
That too.
How do you improve?
So how do you balance both the things?
Such a great question.
I'm so glad you asked that because I think what the,
what we have to ask yourself is where is our point of attraction?
So from before I was like trying to reach that number on the scale or we're
trying to improve ourselves from a place of self hate or desperation or I'm not
good enough.
But once I found self love and when you're in an empowered place,
that means you can make the changes from an empowered place.
It doesn't mean we just settle.
It doesn't mean we just say,
oh forget it.
I'm a healthier and happier than I've ever been today and making the best
choices for me.
Even though society may say an overweight person,
you know,
doesn't isn't that way.
So for you and anyone who trying to improve,
it's about saying,
I'm going to do this because I love myself and I care about myself and I'm going
to honor myself and then watch your results come a lot faster.
So,
in essence,
what you're saying is anything that you do should be in order driven and not
externally driven.
Somebody has.
Sure,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And I get that we have bosses that need stuff from us.
Right.
So you guys,
I'll walk out.
You're like,
shit,
that's the,
we don't have to,
don't do that.
No,
but I believe that the internal,
the reason we feel this anxiety and this pain and we go home feeling like
something's missing is because we're still looking out there.
Once we turn inward and there's a process I take people through in the book to
really align,
then yes.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
I feel like we should clap
just for standing up.
That takes courage.
Any other questions?
Hello?
Hi.
Thank you.
You did great.
Um,
so my question is,
um,
as a child,
like what,
what did you see around you that made you start to
lack that confidence?
Right?
Like what were the reinforcements and know if it's not too personal,
sometimes we pick up things as children.
I know you talked a little bit about like rejection from the basketball team,
but like at home,
like what was your family not um,
encouraging you,
your siblings,
your aunts,
your uncles?
And I asked that because I know that that's been like an experience for me where
it's like I don't,
I didn't get that love reinforcement at home.
And then I found out later,
well the last few years it dawned on me like,
yeah,
my mom didn't have it.
Her parents weren't around on,
they'll have it.
Her parents weren't around,
you know?
So I think it's a beautiful question.
Absolutely.
And actually in the book I talk about it.
Yeah.
If you want,
I talk about it too because there's a principle in the book.
In order to find self love,
we have to be who we needed to be when we were younger because for all of us
men,
to answer this in a layered way,
if we get really clear and honest with ourselves from age like maybe seven to
nine,
usually something happens.
Something happens in every person's life.
Where we are ourself,
we do what we feel is natural.
But the world tells us that's wrong.
So for me,
I really love ice cream.
I loved it as a kid.
It was fun and it was part of how I related to my dad cause he loves sweet
stuff.
But my mom would say,
no,
don't eat the ice cream.
Like really bad.
And so I saw the way she looked at me,
I saw the way she treated me when I did what it felt natural.
Like I'm just talking about food,
but there's other situations in our life.
Um,
and I shied away.
So it turned into an eating disorder at a very young age where I'd have to hide
something that felt natural.
Now if she would've said,
okay,
maybe you can have a couple bites or something,
then maybe I want to turn it into me feeling bad about doing what I want.
So instead of blaming our parents,
right,
they do the best they could.
We as adults still feel like there's a piece of us now there could it,
maybe it wasn't eating for you,
but maybe you want it to be a dancer and your parents wanted you to be an
athlete or maybe you want to be an artist.
Like the all these things that we shy away from.
So the point is as an adult,
give yourself what you needed as a child that was missing.
And there's a process I take you through in the book as well,
which is really healing because I realized I had a great childhood,
very loving,
but I was bullied because I was the new kid all the time and I would eat and you
know,
overweight child.
So wherever you were,
go back to your childhood,
go back to that point where you first realized,
oh my gosh,
I was just being me in the world,
said I got made fun of for being me.
Or you know,
and then give yourself as an adult that love that respect and attention and then
forgive your parents because they do the best they can and they don't even know
better.
And we can do better for us.
Thank you.
Good question that answer it.
Any other questions?
Can you give a bad answer?
I get dry.
Um,
I just have one,
one more question.
Um,
you talked a lot about the tools and I love what you actually just added more
tools on to what you already talked about.
What are your favorite tools when it comes to self love or self care?
Yeah,
that's beautiful.
So I like the hand on the heart,
which I shared with you guys,
but actually one of the beautiful things about the book is I am really big
believer on asking yourself questions and then giving your tie yourself time to
answer.
So I've put all the questions I asked in the book in the back in like a format
so you could do a joy journal or free ride on it.
But one of my favorite favorites,
his letters to yourself.
So letters to your future self.
When I was stuck in depression,
I had no idea that there was such thing as a happy life.
Someone who enjoyed their career.
And I was like,
Dear Future Shannon,
what message do you have for me?
And so I encourage you guys to the one who has it figured out,
the one who is not suffering.
And then there's also a letter to her past self.
So now I write a letter to the one who was depressed and stuck and like,
oh,
it's gonna work out.
Just stay with it like don't give up.
Or the most challenging one is letter to the part of you that is struggling.
So I said,
dear overweight body,
why are you here?
What do you have to teach me?
And it said,
you are here to love yourself no matter what.
I'm here to show you that how you look.
Self love is not how you look.
It's about how you live.
So we can get profound answers when we just allow ourselves the space and time
to go inward.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Do you ever mail the letters of yourself?
I should,
but I haven't.
Yeah,
that would be really fun.
I have crazy journals piled up all over.
So
I did a,
it's a,
it's something similar a few years ago when I was a yoga teacher and had a whole
class write letters to portray ourselves.
That's something I gave it to me and I held onto her for two years and then I
ended up sending them.
That's all spent.
You guys should all go home today,
write a letter and then mail it to yourself or give it to someone that you trust
and then have them mail it to you.
It's really fun.
It's actually fantastic.
And it's about celebrating you and saying,
you know what,
start starts saying like,
you're doing a good job.
I appreciate you.
Like we did good today.
Like we need to be our own cheerleaders.
I love it.
Any last questions from the audience?
Yes.
Come on up.
Hi.
Um,
I guess my question is regarding,
or if you touch on the book at all on external love and when that,
I guess came back into your life or,
um,
where you feel like that balance comes.
Yeah.
Actually that's beautiful.
Um,
so a lot of the work that I do is about learning how to be your own hero.
A lot of the,
you talking about like maybe romantic love.
So for beef,
yes.
So there is a part in there and there's,
it's,
it's actually layered throughout.
Um,
I don't have one specific tool,
but I will say that it's conducive on when you truly love yourself,
you can bring the love into your life that is really long lasting and who loves
themselves too.
So I also think that every relationship we're in at every stage of our life is
an opportunity and a teacher and a lesson.
So every relationship leading up to the soulmate has become a profound kind of
helping me become more of who I need to be.
And I think for all of us as well.
But it is very much you come to relationships from a place of not needing them
to fill you up,
whereas you are full and saying,
I accept myself and love myself and you are adding to my life and where in this
glorious adventure together,
which is a beautiful place to be.
Yeah.
I have a lot of articles too on that,
like I write for Huffington post and Mindbodygreen,
so just type in relationships.
Shannon Kaiser might come up.
Yeah.
All right.
Can we get a big round of [inaudible]
for Shannon?
Thank you.